we like kids to know that all dreams are
possible if you believe in yourself
natalia bryant may have her heart set on
going to college in new york
but her mom isn't really feeling that
she's amazing
i was there i was there helping you know
doing everything i possibly can to make
the process easier for my wife
but ultimately you know she did all the
work i was just there just trying to
help her out
on wednesday vanessa bryant hit up
instagram to share this shot of her
oldest daughter
rocking a new york university sweatshirt
and in the caption
she said she's doing what mamas do
trying to convince her baby
not to fly too far from the nest she
wrote in part
quote so cute nyu is one of her top
schools i will do my best to keep her
and cali just like i kept her daddy here
hashtag cali girl forever and it seems
like vanessa just might get her wish
shortly after she posted that nyu pic
she shared
this shot of the 17 year old posing in a
university of southern california
t-shirt
giving a fight on to the camera our
responsibility is to always inspire
and try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned
and share those with the next generation
so that they can start
their journey with a leg up it's been
almost a year since vanessa's husband
kobe bryant and their 13 year old
daughter gianna as well as seven other
victims
died in a tragic helicopter crash
outside of la on january 26th
since then the bryant family has leaned
on the support of good friends
and last month natalia opened up on
instagram about surrounding herself with
people she could count on
quote it is so important to find your
close circle of trusted people
and be able to vocalize your feelings to
them when you are ever down or not
feeling like yourself
this is also a lot easier said than done
but just know
that you are never alone this is
something i have learned throughout this
year
and still continue to work at with the
help of close family and friends
i talked to her every single day and
just you know continue to
pray for her and stay positive for her
back in april etie caught up with one of
vanessa's trusted people
lala anthony who opened up about how
strong her friend is
i tell her every day she's the strongest
woman i know and
i'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend she's
just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing